- People who have put a
headset, can you hear me fine?
Can you raise your hand
if you can hear me fine?
Awesome. Perfect.
First of all, thank you so much
for being here on a Wednesday
morning in Vegas at 8:30,
and choosing us versus
Swami, I appreciate it.
So this is IND 3303,
Moody's: Architecting a
multi-agent system on AWS.
My name is Samuel Baruffi,
and I'm Principal
Solutions Architect at AWS.
And I have the pleasure to
have with me Dennis Climent.
Dennis is a managing director,
Engineering and Architecture
for Moody's Digital
Content and Innovation.
So in the next 60 minutes or so, me
and Dennis are gonna
go through the journey
that we've been working together
on how Moody's have revolutionized
their way of thinking
and serving their customers
through an agentic system.
Before I get started, maybe
can I ask a question for the audience?
And you can just raise your hand.
How many of you are
currently building agents?
Okay. A majority.
How many of you are in the
financial service industry?
Okay, awesome. The
majority of you as well.
So hopefully this will
be very useful for you.
A quick look at the agenda on
what we're gonna cover today.
We're gonna start with Dennis taking us
through their journey from
almost three years ago
on how they saw a opportunity
of revolutionizing their business
through the lens of generative AI.
What was the vision? What
was the challenges they face?
After that, we're gonna go through some
of the technical foundational services
that they're currently using on AWS
to implement and deliver those
services through agentic AI.
And of course, this is a
technical session, Dennis is
gonna take us through the
architecture they decided
on taking, some of the
challenges they face,
how they solved those challenges,
and how they actually
evolve from a simple chatbot
through a multi-agent system on AWS.
And a very important,
I think, lesson learned
that Dennis is gonna share with us is,
financial services have a
lot of unstructured data.
How do you actually retrieve insights
for those financial documents
into a structured ability
to use that into agents, right?
And then Dennis and I also
gonna share a little bit more,
looking forward, what is the vision
and what the future entitles.
So I'm gonna pass it over
to Dennis to kick us off.
- Thanks Sam. So good morning,
so I'm Dennis Climent.
I'm a managing director at
Moody's Analytics, and I lead one
of the largest engineering
teams focused on generative AI.
Now, this is a team that has been
producing actual production-grade
generative AI products
since about 2023.
So I'm gonna show you
how a 100-year old
financial institution is
redefining what is possible
with a multi-agentic system on AWS.
So I need to start with who we are,
because I think it's really important
to understand who we are
so that you know why
we built what we built.
So yes, Moody's is a 100-year
old credit rating agency,
right, but that's what's actually
really interesting, right?
That hundred years of
domain knowledge is actually
what makes us really, really dangerous
in the gen AI space, right?
We are not a tech company trying
to understand financial institutions.
We are the, like, preemptive service
that financial institutions need
to solve their problems, right?
We serve over 1,500 customers
across 165 countries,
97% of the Fortune 100.
And this is all not just ratings anymore.
We are doing risk intelligence
across a bunch of
different domains, right?
We are doing credit, climate, economics,
compliance, right, you name it.
And folks aren't coming to
Moody's, right, just to browse.
They are making billion
dollar decisions, right,
across a ton of their own
internal systems, right,
and we need a strategic
AI strategy, right,
for customers to actually
make a difference
on a day-to-day basis, right?
So one of the big challenges
that we have is the fact
that we have a lot of
different types of customers
that are coming into our systems.
We have commercial banks
running loan origination,
and they need a multitude
of different data sets
to solve some of their problems.
We have asset managers, right,
that need climate risk models
to do portfolio analysis.
We have insurance companies
that need regulatory
compliance validation.
So it's the same platform,
but very, very different
problems to solve.
So this is our, like, one
pager of our data universe,
because understanding this
complexity is key, right,
to understanding what we built.
So we have about four core
pillars in our data universe.
Ratings, research and
insights, data and information,
and decision solutions.
And we create our own
authoritative data sets
through our ratings agencies.
So this is decades of research
documents, credit opinions,
sector outlooks, right, you name it.
Now we also operate Orbis, which is one
of the largest databases of
company or an entity data
in the world, this is
600 million entities.
And we are creating climate risk analysis,
we are doing economic forecasts,
we do know your customer
screening, we do regulatory filing.
So as you can see, the
scale is pretty incredible.
So with all of this,
we have to truly focus
on being accessible, accurate, and fast.
So the question is, how do
you build an AI system, right,
that takes all of this into account.
So our customer diversity,
right, is what really
drives, you know, why we cannot compromise
on accuracy, right?
You gotta look at who relies on us?
2,600 commercial banks
processing loan originations,
1,900 asset managers making
portfolio allocation decisions,
and 800 plus insurance companies, right,
running regulatory stress tests.
These aren't, like, low
stakes, right, use cases.
And that's why, right, we're
introducing generative AI
into our system was challenging.
And so this is just a list
of industry awards, right?
This right here really is our
accountability markers, right?
This is what, why we
deliver precision, right?
Our SaaS products, right,
carry the Moody's name.
And when our company makes,
like, certain credit decisions,
and certain risk profiles,
the market moves, right?
So this is why, right, we really needed
to think through why our AI systems need
to work for high-stake
financial environments.
So this is where our journey
though really begins,
not truly technical, right,
but what forced us to kind
of rethink everything.
And this is the big
fundamental tension, right,
that we faced, right?
When a commercial bank is making
$500 million loan decisions
or an asset manager is
rebalancing a $2 billion portfolio, right,
99% accuracy just isn't good enough.
That missing 1%, right,
could be catastrophic, right?
So let me paint a little picture, right,
of why this is so hard, right?
Look at the complexity we're dealing with.
A single customer, right,
comes to us needing expertise
across all of our different
domains: credit ratings,
sector analysis, economic comparisons,
and regulatory compliance,
all of this simultaneously.
And they just aren't adjacent domains,
these are different
knowledge universes, right?
And they require separate
analyst teams, right?
Now, not only that, we are also
in a regulated space, right?
So we have to think about compliance.
We think we have to think
about data separation.
When users actually input
their data into our systems,
we have to think about
true data isolation, right?
And so all of this, right, means
that we needed to make really,
really specific decisions
about how we were producing
our products, right?
And what makes it even harder is,
our customers aren't just
querying Moody's data,
they want their own data as well, right?
And so they are uploading
financial documents,
they're uploading PDFs into
our system, and we have
to seamlessly kind of merge
not only our expertise, right,
but also with their data sets, right,
to solve real world problems, right?
And let me tell you the PDF reality
and that unstructured
data, that is difficult,
and we are still tackling it,
and we're still fighting that fight,
but hopefully a winning fight.
So now we'll give you a little
bit of how we evolved, right?
Now this timeline tells our story.
We started like most people did, right,
with a RAG application, right?
So we deployed our research assistant
about December of 2023,
and users loved it.
They got answers grounded
in real research, right?
And it was able to truly
solve a lot of their problems.
But the moment somebody asks
something truly complex, right,
where you're comparing risk,
right, for multiple companies,
their financial metrics,
right, across your portfolio,
analyzing news, all of
that, is when it started
to kind of crumble.
These scenarios were very difficult
for a basic RAG application to solve.
Then in August, 2024,
we got the understanding
that people wanted to introduce their data
into our world, right?
So we released our first
PDF upload capability.
And that is where a
customer adds their data
into our systems to solve
real world problems, right?
And that is where, I would say,
that's where our unstructured data story
kind of even begins, 'cause
that's where we really started
to realize where we needed
to upskill ourselves and our systems.
And now in the end of
2025, it's the culmination
of all of that, right?
We have learned from our customers,
we have created custom orchestrators
with specialized workflows,
with specific task agents
all sitting there trying
to solve a designated
task, right, for our users.
And all of this powered
by AWS's infrastructure,
operating agentic loops, and
all the sorts of evaluations
that we need for our systems.
So here is how this kind of
works in practice, right?
This is Moody's research assistant.
And this was our first gen AI chatbot
released, again, in 2023.
And you'll see it's a
simple interface, right?
But behind the scenes,
there's so much complexity.
This is a specialized
intent engine, right,
routing to the right expertise,
routing to the right data
that is necessary.
It quickly provides context, right?
And it delivers really fast
and reliable answers, right?
And it's all grounded in real data.
And let me tell you, we
painstakingly cite everything
that we can do, right?
Because when we do that, right,
this is what gives our customers,
right, the continued trust
in what we are doing and how
we are serving our clients.
But this is where kind of
our vision really went.
And this is what changed
everything for us, right?
We spent much of our times
in research assistant,
tweaking prompts, tweaking
the intent engine,
and all of these for really small gains.
And we realized early
that the future, right,
isn't better prompts, it's
better context, right?
Research assistant,
right, was proven though.
It was saving people 60%,
it was giving people 60%
faster insights, right?
It was 30% reduction in task completions.
And we were processing decades
of Moody's proprietary research, right?
All to serve our clients.
But we realized that we can do even more.
And we realized that
there were certain things
that this chatbot was
just not doing for us.
So we moved from, let's ask
a question and get an answer
to let's orchestrate
specialist intelligence, right?
And this is how we were
going to move forward.
So now I'm gonna let Sam
kind of show you what the foundations
kind of helped build all of these systems.
- Thank you, Dennis.
So before Dennis takes us to the journey
on how they've implemented AWS services
and AWS infrastructure
into their agentic system,
let's just quickly go
through some of the services
and high level idea on how they work.
The journey that Dennis
just took us through
is what we've seen in
financial service industries
and other industries as well.
And I really like this slide,
because it kind of demonstrate
exactly the journey
that they've taken.
They've started with research assistant
as a generative AI assistant back in 2023.
They started creating specialized
agents as the next step.
Then as mentioned, the PDF upload.
And of course, they're now working
and have released agentic
AI systems as part
of a more autonomous
multi-agent system collaboration
that he's gonna spend
a little bit more time
dive deeping in a moment.
But how do you achieve
that with AWS services?
Well, there are multiple services.
We start of course, with Amazon Bedrock.
If you watch the keynote
from Matt yesterday,
Amazon Bedrock is not just a
service, it is a full ecosystem
of services that allow companies
across different industries
to build-production grade workloads
through agents and foundational models.
The most important aspect
of this is the ability
to choose models from different providers
in a true serverless fashion,
which Moody's is currently doing.
But if you have different use cases
such as you require a RAG database
and you need a managed ingestion pipeline,
Bedrock has also capabilities
which allow you to do that.
Now, one of the challenges
of moving agentic systems
from a simple chatbot
through a multi-agent
orchestration that requires a lot
of tokens from foundational models,
is how do you achieve that capacity?
So this year,
Bedrock was very heavy at
work on helping customers
with more capacity and
the capability of expand.
There are two features
within the Bedrock inference
of foundation models that
I wanna touch base first.
The first one is what we
call the global cross-region inference.
The way it work is previous one, Bedrock,
was released two and a half years ago,
you could call a model
within a single region.
So on this slide here, I'm showing
if I have a specific application
running on a container
on a Lambda, you could call
Bedrock within the region
and that region will have a specific limit
and capacity for a specific model.
What Bedrock now allows you to do is
if you enable the global
cross-region inference endpoint,
and if you see at the
bottom of this screen,
this is the inference profile ID
that you can pick when
building applications,
what that allows you to do is
if the region that you are
located doesn't have capacity
or you have achieved
the limits of the region
for your specific account,
it can automatically have a routing
using the internal backbone of AWS network
and ask the question, where
is there available capacity
that is closer to my user
across commercial regions
that Bedrock and that model is available.
This model of course,
is Claude Sonnet 4.5.
There are multiple models
that support a global
cross-region inference endpoint.
So in that case, Bedrock behind
the scenes will route you
to a specific region that has capacity.
In this slide, we've chosen
ap-southeast-1, keep in mind
that everything behind the scenes is
using the AWS network backbone.
So nothing is going through the internet.
And if you also go and hit the limits
of that specific region, Bedrock can then
redirect the traffic across
any commercial available region
that that model is available.
So what that allows you to do,
of course, increases your
resiliency, increases the limits
that you can actually
call that specific model
for your specific application.
Now, a very common challenge,
the financial services
companies face, are you need
to be bound at a specific
geographic location.
Maybe you have some data
residency requirements,
maybe you have some regulatory
compliance that you need
to obey that it can only serve
a specific geographic region.
Now you can still call
just a specific region,
and that is fine, but you have
the limits of the capacity
of Bedrock and that model
within that specific region.
What we introduced as well,
we call geographic cross-region inference.
It works very similar
to a global cross-region
inference endpoint.
The difference is, rather than
picking a global endpoint,
you choose a specific geographic location.
For example, Europe, US, Asia.
And what happens behind the scenes is
if the capacity, in
this case for eu-west-1,
have been hit, breached, from your account
and you need more capacity,
behind the scenes working the same way
that I explained on global endpoint,
we'll find another region
within Europe specifically
and we redirect the traffic
to that specific endpoint
for that specific model.
And of course, there are more
regions that support Bedrock
within the European regions,
and that allows you to do that.
Now why is that important?
If you are in within a regulated industry,
you can still keep the data
within the geographic region
while you increasing the capacity
and the ability for you
to serve multiple agents
that requires a higher
throughput of tokens.
So that is definitely
something Moody's is using
to help them orchestrate it
across multiple regions, their system.
Now Dennis mentioned multiple
times about the challenge
of embedding unstructured data
into a RAG vector database.
And part of the Bedrock service ecosystem,
we have something called
Knowledge Base for Amazon Bedrock.
What this allows you to do is
to have a fully managed
end-to-end RAG workflow.
So it just not only gives you the ability
to embed documents into a vector database,
it focus on the whole ingestion pipeline
for a broad document, a PDF sitting on S3,
for parsing the document,
to creating chunks
for the document, embedding the document,
and saving a vector database,
and giving you the ability
to choose multiple ways you
wanna retrieve that document.
So it's a completely fully
managed solution that allows you
to have a peace of mind rather than trying
to manage every single
component of the stack.
You can just rely on AWS
with Bedrock Knowledge Base.
So how does that work?
If you look at the data
ingestion workflow,
let's assume you have
different file formats.
You have text documents,
you have PDF documents,
you might even have some
multimodality documents,
maybe some audio files,
maybe some video files.
And you want that, that
insight from that data
to be by the end of the day
in a vector store that you can retrieve.
So the way Knowledge Base
works is you choose a S3 bucket
where you save those files
within that S3 bucket.
That S3 bucket will, you
know, evolve with time,
maybe you're gonna have updated documents,
you're gonna have new documents.
Knowledge base can keep an eye
and update the ingestion pipeline for you.
Once, if it realizes
there is a new document,
there is an updated document,
it can do the parsing.
There are multiple ways you
can choose to do the parsing.
You can use the default way
for Bedrock Knowledge Base.
You can use a large language
model to parse the document.
And you can also use what we
call Bedrock Data Automation,
which is the last service
I'm gonna mention today.
Once it does that,
you decide what chunking
strategy you wanna use,
you might wanna use a
fixed chunking strategy,
you might wanna do your chunking strategy
with the Lambda function,
which allows you to do that.
And Moody's is actually
using the capability.
And after that you can
choose an embedding model.
So the embedding models are
available within Bedrock.
We have Amazon Titan, Amazon
Nova multimodal embedding model
that we just released about
three weeks or so ago,
and also the Cohere embedding models.
Now, if you don't wanna
use some of these models
and you wanna use maybe some open source,
open weight models, you can also
host those embedding models on SageMaker
and point Knowledge Base into SageMaker.
And finally, because Bedrock wants
to provide you with flexibility, you can
choose the vector database you
wanna use behind the scenes.
You can use OpenSearch Serverless
where you don't need to
manage any infrastructure.
You can use some partners as
well, such as Pinecone, Redis.
If you are into more relational databases,
and you're very familiar with
Postgres, you can do pgvector
and use either Aurora
pgvector or RDS pgvector.
And the list is bigger as well.
We've just announced yesterday
the general availability
of S3 Vectors, which
is the ability for you
to store vectors into S3
with 90% price performance comparing
to traditional vector databases.
Now Dennis is gonna talk to us
about how they've taken the
very, very fundamental challenge
of unstructured data.
So you have these PDFs.
These PDFs are full of complex
financial tables, graphs.
How do we extract not only
the text from those PDFs,
but the insights, the
tables, in the proper format?
Actually, there was a study
that was done by Amazon that 80%
of the data in financial
service is unstructured, right?
It could be in maybe 10-Q
documents, maybe can be an audio
or a video from a financial reporting
that the company has, the earning reported
that the company published.
But only 20% of organizations
are actually currently able
to take an advantage of
this unstructured data.
So we've introduced, a year or so ago,
another capability on Bedrock.
It's called Bedrock Data Automation.
So for those specific
challenging documents
that you have a lot of different
data, unstructured data,
how can you actually choose, just
put all the unstructured document into S3,
and how can you actually
extract the insights from that?
Well, you can use Bedrock Data Automation.
And the way Bedrock Data
Automation works are two ways.
The first way you can call
Bedrock Data Automation
as a traditional API.
And you can pass the document, it can be,
so it supports multimodality,
so it supports audio, video,
image, and documents.
Dennis gonna go through how they've
used Bedrock Data Automation
for financial documents,
like very complex, long financial PDFs.
So you put the document,
you choose the capability of extraction.
So you can do summary, you can
do text, you can do fields.
And we've actually seen a weight increase
of performance and accuracy
when using Bedrock data automation
instead of traditional
large language model.
The hallucination distraction
of a foundational model versus
Bedrock Data Automation,
you can actually gain
advantage both from price
and also accuracy performance
with Bedrock Data Automation.
So with that said, I'll
pass it back to Dennis,
whence he's gonna go through
the architecture deep dive
on how they've implemented their
agentic system of database.
Over to you, Dennis.
- All right, now the fun
part, let's get technical.
So I'm gonna walk you through
how we actually built this,
and the architectural
decisions that we've made,
and the theory, right,
around how we put our theory
into production reality.
So again, the evolution, right?
So everybody raise your hand here
if you've built a RAG
application, all right?
So all of us have started with that.
It's the initial
deployment that we all do.
It's a RAG system, one model,
one context window, right?
Trying to solve everything, right?
And so users started
to ask about credit risk, sector analysis,
all of that fun stuff.
And this one system had to be
an expert in all of it, right?
And the cracks appeared
immediately, right?
So context window limitations,
performance degradations, right?
And just shallow expertise, right?
And so we were really
asking the impossible.
So we kind of made a few series
of realizations, right?
The first one is financial
intelligence, right?
That should mirror how
we as humans, right,
and expert teams actually view some
of these problems, right?
And it requires specialized
expertise, right?
Second, we noticed that
our users were asking,
now we're not asking
just random questions,
they were orchestrating
repeatable workflows, right?
And then third, it's
context switching, right?
Just like a human context switching,
switching kills performance, right?
Even similar expertise
benefits from true isolation,
and agentic systems need
that focused context, right?
So the answer we came up
with was deep specialists,
intelligent coordination,
right, and repeatable patterns.
So this was the fundamental shift, right?
No more prompt engineering, right?
But true context engineering, right?
So before we dive into this, right?
Raise your hand if you spent
hours tweaking a prompt.
Yeah. All right?
And I bet you a bunch of you
also hit a really brick wall
and at some point no
tweaking was ever going
to solve that problem, right?
And that's the reality of the systems
that we've built, right?
We have to move away from
prompt engineering, right,
that optimizes little instructions
and little parameters here and there.
And we pray to the LLM gods
and voila, we probably fall short, right?
So here's what we learned, right?
The breakthrough wasn't
about better prompts, right?
It was about better
context boundaries, right?
These multi-agentic architectures,
these multi-agentic workflows, right,
they own precise context
boundaries, right,
about their specific domain.
No cross-domain interference.
There's no diluted expertise, all right?
So here I'm gonna give
you a little context
into our workflow system.
Do I have to?
- Just click, yeah.
- Nice. So in late 2023,
around 2024, right?
We're running research assistant
and customers loved it,
but we started to see a real
specific pattern, right?
Users were asking questions
like pull credit ratings
for these five companies, right?
Now, do an analysis of their
financial metrics, right?
Compare it to news,
and cross reference it
with some sector research.
They were forcing chain of
thought, right, through our chat.
So that's when we realized.
They don't want smarter chatbots, right?
They want the orchestration power, right?
They want to visually
stitch together Moody's expertise, right?
Into repeatable workflows.
And so to create, like, really
specialized outputs, right?
Which this means charts,
graphs, tables, you name it.
So we built this. This
is our workflow designer.
This is before OpenAI's Agent Builder.
This is before most orchestration
platforms existed, right?
We built it, because
our customers needed it.
This was true customer empowerment.
And so our system here, right, has gone
from, you know, a 20-step workflow
to 400-step workflows, right?
It will take anything from
a couple minutes, right,
to 15 plus, right?
But what you get is a
structured output, right,
of our expertise, right, that ourselves
and our customers were able
to stitch together, right,
to solve real world problems.
And I will say this is
probably one of those systems
that we realized that we needed to create.
This wasn't about something
that our users, like, came to us
and like theorized, right?
This was us understanding
what users wanted,
why they needed it, right,
and how we were gonna solve
some of their problems.
But we're very proud of this.
So now the fun stuff, right?
So I wanna dive deep into,
like, the architecture, right,
and go through this,
but first I wanna align
on terminology, right?
So I'd be really interested
to ask this, right?
So how many times have
any of you been asked
by some executive inside of
your company to say, "Hey,
I want you to ingest all of our documents.
I want it to be able to
ask any question you want.
And I want it to be a hundred
percent accurate?" 100%.
And then they also ask you that they need
that probably tomorrow
or next month, right?
That's just not realistic.
And they also say, "Hey,
can't you just throw some agents at this?"
Now I think it's really,
really, really important
for us to understand,
right, the terminology.
If we align on the terminology,
we can have a lot better
of a conversation, right?
So here I'm gonna talk
through what we, in our team,
have aligned on what are tools,
what are agents, and what
are workflows, right?
So tool, right, is a system
that performs a very specific task.
It is a process, it returns
context back to an LLM, right?
Think of it as a discreet process.
So you are fetching data, right?
You are doing calculations, right?
And it is isolated, right?
So an agent for us, right,
is again, an LLM, right?
It's autonomously choosing tools.
It's operating in some
form of loop, right?
And it determines when
it's task is complete.
Now, yes, I know that
sounds smart, all right?
But it's not Skynet, right?
We all know what it truly is, right?
Which is a, honestly, it's a for loop
with kind of better PR.
Now a workflow, right?
That is a deterministic
orchestration, right?
This is a predefined
sequence of steps, right?
That we are coordinating tools, right,
agents, something along those lines
to get a very consistent output, right?
So, but fundamentally, right,
tools can also be agents,
agents can also be tools, right?
But the real reality here is
these are just the building blocks, right,
that we have built this system on.
So with this, right, I want to talk
through kind of like the five
pillars that changed, right?
Or the five pillars that
we've thought through, right,
in orchestrating the system.
And so the first is we strive
to be serverless, right?
The financial world
that we live in is
incredibly spiky, right?
So at any moment, credit
risk, a credit change happens,
and we go from baseline users
on our site to 50x, right?
And that is just the way we work.
So we built our agentic systems
in that kind of same way,
truly understanding that we
were gonna use the foundations
of our serverless architecture, right,
to perform the agentic tasks
that we also need, right?
And so second is we learned that tools,
the tools that perform, like, operations,
those are the essential building blocks.
So we wanted to focus on how
do we surface those tools
to agentic systems and to the
company as a whole, right?
And that we chose to do in Lambdas, right?
So the reason for this is,
because they are single
purpose, they are fast, right?
And they are stateless, right?
And so this allows us
to, again, have a ton of different sets
of workflows or agents
utilizing the same tools,
and it will be able to scale with us.
So third is our agents, right?
And we build kind of
like two types of agents.
There are simple agents, right?
And these are some form
of system prompt, right?
A set of curated tools, some
validation steps, right?
We serve those all in some
form of a JSON object, right?
So that we can just run
them at will, right?
And then they get orchestrated
by our orchestrating systems right?
Now then we have complex agents, right?
And these are, honestly,
it's just custom built software, right?
It is again, Lambda's, I'm
sorry, it is tools, right?
It is our data sets,
and it is code, right?
And all of that kind of
stitched together, right,
in our world as an ECS.
Why? Because a lot of times
those require state, right?
They are long running in nature, right?
One of the caveats
to using Lambdas always
is you have to remember,
they're not great for
giant amount of compute.
They have a limit to I
think 15 minutes or so
before they will crap out on us.
So ECSs on the other hand,
give us that stateful information, right?
They allow us to have
long running tasks, right?
And that is kind of how we
push those things forward.
And then fourth here is going
to be our orchestrator, right?
And that is the brains to
this whole operation, right?
So our custom built
orchestration system, right, will
take, again, in JSON
format, your list of tools,
your list of agents, your
list of prompts, right?
All were orchestrated
together, right, in an ECS.
But the complexity there
that we've built into our orchestrator is
behind the scenes, right?
So inside of this, we are juggling the act
of it being performant, right?
It being cost effective, right?
And so we are paralleling
as many of these steps
as humanly possible, right?
But we're also understanding
that, you know, you need
to have x amount of these
steps finished, right,
before the next step is allowed to go.
And we kind of, we do all the magic there.
Now, the concerted effort here, right,
has been to save costs,
right, to handle our errors,
anytime we get throttled by
our LLM providers, right?
That's the real power in our orchestrator.
And so our lead engineer,
when he created this,
he set a max limit to about
20 or so steps, right?
Because none of us thought
in any way, shape, or form
that you would need more than 20 tools
or 20 steps to ever solve a problem.
Now, some of our customer workflows are
over 400 steps, right?
And so that really blows your
mind about understanding,
like, what people are trying
to do inside of our systems.
And last kind of like
architectural decision
that we needed to make was,
you know, what LLMs to choose.
And we made a concerted
effort not to be pigeonholed
into a specific model,
right, for our systems.
So every agent, every step,
every tool has the ability
to choose a very specific
LLM for its needs, right?
And so these are things
that we can then test,
validate, right, and push forward
as small isolated systems.
So one of our agents could
use a reasoning model
and another one could use
even a small language model
for small computational pieces, right?
So let's take a step back, right?
And we can talk through
the numbers, right?
So we have about 80 or so tools.
We have a hundred plus workflows, right?
We have many specialized
task agents themselves,
and we're processing over a
million tokens a day, right?
And I just want you to know,
like, this isn't a demo,
this is in production today, right,
satisfying our customer's needs.
All right, so I wanna
take a moment here though
and talk about something
that is truly near
and dear to all of our hearts, right?
So we spent some time talking
about the sophistication
around our orchestration systems, right,
our workflows, our agents, right?
But none of that works, right,
if you do not have the context, right,
to give our agents, right?
So this is our fundamental PDF processing
and retrieval challenge.
Now, in our industry, like Sam said,
everything is a PDF, right?
10-Qs have hundreds of pages.
Annual reports, again,
are hundreds of pages,
earnings reports as well.
There are regulatory filings, right?
And all of this is a challenge, right?
And LLMs are brilliant
at reasoning, right?
But without the right context,
what is it actually going to do?
So we actually call this,
like, an archeological dig problem, right?
You are trying to excavate
layers of buried information
across hundreds of different pages, right?
A table header can be on one page, right?
But the actual table can
span two, three pages afterwards, right?
There are charts, there are
images, there are infographics,
there's text all over the place.
There are footnotes that
aren't always attached
to what you think they
should be attached to, right?
And, you know, that was
kind of a fundamental issue.
All of these PDFs are always,
the layouts are different, right?
And so they needed a very unique way
of trying to solve all of our problems.
And the reality is, in a
financial world, right,
one decimal, right, that's off
could represent a catastrophic change
to a customer and what they need, right?
So I think one of the biggest bottlenecks
in our financial AI, right,
continues to be this,
the complexity around trying to deal
with this unstructured data.
So how do we tackle this, right?
And I wanna say like a good
engineering team, right,
we tried everything
that seemed reasonable,
some things that seemed unreasonable.
We over-engineered a bunch of things,
and we also under engineered
a bunch of things.
So I'm gonna go through all
the ways that we failed, right?
And this is how we can
be an honest engineering team together.
Because I think in noticing
what, where we have failed,
hopefully that can help
you as you are reaching
for your solutions, right?
So first, like a lot of us, right,
we started with basic
Python libraries, right?
It goes, it extracts a
bunch of the text, right?
And it does it pretty decently
well, and fast and cheap.
But the problem there is
you lose all context, right?
I think about it as
throwing a 200-page document
into a blender, right?
You're gonna get all the parts back out,
but it might not have all the context
that you truly need, right?
So honestly, the verdict
here was it failed.
It did not provide us the
type of context needed
to solve financial problems, right?
So verdict number two, right?
Custom parsing algorithm.
And this is where we
realized that we wanted
to understand the true hierarchy, right,
of a PDF document, right?
So we would go through, we would try
to do some bounding boxes
around certain sections
so that we could group some
of these things together.
This screenshot that
you're seeing on the right
is what that looks like, right?
And that's complex, right?
And it is a little bit
of a crapshoot, right?
It's not always gonna be able
to work, it's not always going
to be able to scale
with the different types
of documents that get thrown at it.
So the reality there,
it also failed, right?
It wasn't able to scale for us, right?
And then approach number three, right,
was like our multimodal
foundational models, right?
And that makes sense, right?
We now have vision models.
We should be able to look
at these PDFs, right,
just like as a human would,
an LLM should be able
to do the same thing.
And honestly it did pretty well, right?
But we definitely found that
certain complex tables, right,
definitely certain complex layouts, right,
it would just struggle, right?
And it wasn't able to be
as accurate as we wanted.
And the reality? That was
very, very costly, right?
So thinking about how to do that at scale
was gonna be very, very difficult, right?
So the verdict here as well, failed.
It's gonna be too pricey, right?
And it just got just enough things wrong
to make it not usable in production.
And last, right?
So this is our 1 million context windows.
Once those babies came out,
we were like, ah, look,
this is gonna solve all
of our problems, right?
We can just throw these entire
giant documents in there
and it will be able to
understand them all.
And also, did really,
really, really well, right?
Of course, though the problem is here,
larger the documents,
the more you stuff into a context window,
the more you are going to start
to degrade what comes out.
And the reality here too is
this is expensive, right?
This is incredibly hard to scale, right?
So here we have it, four approaches,
all of them failed, right,
to reach the kind of requirements
that we need in the financial industry.
But the reality is we learned
so much from this, right?
And we weren't going to just stop.
Our clients need this,
need this solved, right?
So we needed to learn from our failures.
So that led us here, right?
This is the concept of not
trying to find one solution
to solve our problem, right?
But we would start building pipelines
that could route different content types
to specialized processes,
processors, right?
So the insights were this, right?
Not all pages are created equal, right?
A text heavy narrative page
needs far different processing
than a page dominated by
complex tables, right?
Or charts or graphs, right?
So we built an intelligent
page classification system.
Right? It's an upfront analysis step.
And it could categorize
a page that is dominant,
that is text heavy dominant, right?
And that would go to a Bedrock LLM
that could do OCR for us, right?
And that would then convert
that into markdown, right?
And we have something that
is a lot easier to query.
Now for table dominated pages, this is
where AWS' Bedrock Data
Automation came in,
and BDA became absolutely
essential, right?
BDA is purpose built
for these kind of complex
table extractions.
And honestly it was a
game changer from us.
Traditional table extractors just couldn't
handle the complexity around
these financial documents.
The reality is, even myself,
I look at some of these tables
and I'm even confused, right?
So cheers to anything that
can kind of look at those,
and handle them, right?
So last there is gonna be our
charts and our images, right?
And so those, then we would
go into a vision model, right?
A vision model is able
to look at those, right?
Create some kind of metadata for it
and create something that allows us
to query them in some
form of vector database.
So this multimodal approach is
what finally kind of unlocked the fact
that we have a scalable PDF
processing system, right?
So different modalities, different tools,
intelligent routing, right?
That's kind of the architecture
that solves some of this.
But here's the thing.
This is like maybe half the battle,
maybe even less than
half the battle, right?
The real battle comes
in how do you get this
information then back out
of our systems, right?
So this is where we went into
a kind of different approach
to get our stuff back out, right?
This is about moving away from
a traditional keyword search,
from semantic search, right,
because that all fails to
understand the complexity
around these documents, right?
And here's where like traditional
single shop vector search,
Which then just returns
the top-k chunks, right?
Or combining that with some
form of keyword search.
You run a reranker, right?
You get that information into an LLM,
and you're like, "Ha,
I'm done, this works."
And then you realize it doesn't.
So what we needed to
do, right, is we found
that there were very specific
types of questions, right,
that people were asking us
where the information is
just scattered, right,
across these documents, right?
Think of a use case
where somebody's trying
to find, in an annual
report, the business units
of the entity, right?
Cross reference that with the revenue
that it may have, right?
And then also analyze maybe
its sector information, right?
So this kind of search query, right,
on a document is incredibly complex.
Business units, right,
that exists in one table,
probably stretched around a
couple different pages, right?
The revenue and other kind
of financial metrics are
in another table.
Maybe some of that
information is in a footnote
for some table, right?
And so how do you, how
are you able to pull all
of that stuff together
in a single shot search?
It's just not gonna happen, right?
So this is where we went into
a agentic retrieval, right?
And so we built agentic
retrieval, right, to be,
to look at a document like a
human would look at it, right?
So an agentic retrieval, we
get the user's query, right?
We create a plan off of that, right?
So this means decompose
the queries, right?
Create a search strategy, we
then execute that strategy
that could be multiple different
searches across it, right?
Then it will reflect, right?
Did it actually answer that question?
Was it able to pull down that information?
If not, continue the loop, right?
And then finalize this
by providing the individual chunks, right,
with its proper citations, right?
And so this is truly
intelligent document navigation.
It's not just search, right?
And so to take a step back, right,
into the kind of conversation
that we're having today
about this multi-agentic system is
that this now becomes
one of the tools, right,
inside of our tool belt, right?
This is a tool that now any workflow,
any agent is able to utilize, right?
So that it can pull the right information
at the right time, right,
to solve its needs.
So this as a whole kind of, like,
brings together our
complete solution, right?
We have a bunch of different tools.
We have specific task agents, right?
That work inside of their known
domains, right, orchestrated
across a really complex
orchestration system, right?
All there, right, to solve
a specific customer need.
Now we need to talk
about what's next, right?
And so we're evolving at all times, right?
And our customers realize
that they need our intelligence, right?
But they want to not only just
consume with it, they want
to build with it, and this
led us into MCPs, right,
and our smart APIs.
And a lot of the tools that we have built
and we utilize inside of our
orchestration systems, right,
we are now able to expose
to our customers directly.
Now I think, we were incredibly
fast to the market, right?
And we have been custom
building a lot of our solutions,
because there just weren't
solutions available
to us already.
So I think one of the
next steps that we have
to take internally is really
figure out the, like,
buy versus build, right?
And honestly,
after being on in re:Invent
for the last few days,
we have realized that a lot of the things
that have come out, right, in
Bedrock, in AgentCore are all
going to be things that
we are going to be able
to replace a lot of our
custom code width, right?
And it's gonna be able
to solve our problems.
And all of these utilizing
of these managed services is
gonna reduce a little
bit of our own tech debt.
So speaking of your primitives, right?
Sam's gonna work, go
through AgentCore, right?
And teach you how AWS is
trying to build this, right,
so that you guys can also
have production ready things at scale.
- Thank you, Dennis.
So I'd expect the
majority of you have heard
through re:Invent or
before about AgentCore.
This is not gonna be a deep dive.
This is gonna be a very
high level introduction
of AgentCore.
So AgentCore is an addition
of our Bedrock ecosystem
that gives you primitives
to build production-grade
agents at scale on AWS.
There are eight primitives.
We just announced one, a new
one yesterday that is not here,
because it was an embargo
and I couldn't add it to this slide.
But some of these primitives
that I strongly believe Moody's
will be able to actually use
and benefit from that, are the runtime.
So we start with the
Runtime, which is the ability
for you to have a serverless
compute environment
where you can run agents
with session isolation at the VM level
with the pay-as-you-go
serverless scenario, right?
It supports any framework.
Moody's have built their own framework,
so they can bring their own framework,
they can call whatever model they're using
for specialized agents at any point.
The whole idea of AgentCore
is to give flexibility
and options for users.
You can pick and choose any of
these primitives at any point
and combine with your own solution.
So Runtime is definitely a
big candidate for helping
with the compute power.
But then, Dennis mentioned,
they currently have 80 tools
just for that specific
multi-agentic system.
And I could imagine that tool
list will keep increasing.
We have released AgentCore
Gateway, which allows you
to create a virtual remote MCP server
that has a complete managed
service solution for you
to manage your tools that
maybe can call directly APIs.
You can have Lambda behind the
scenes to add your own logic.
You can even actually call
behind the scenes your
own existing MCP servers
in a centralized platform.
Now, everything that you do, especially
on a such a regulated industry
as financial services,
you wanna make sure you have
proper identity authentication
and authorization, right?
And you separate, when
you think about an agent,
you can think about two types
of authorization, right?
You can think about inbound
authorization, meaning
who is the user accessing the agent
and what are the permissions
that that user have
in order to call that agent.
But then, you know, agentic
systems brings a new challenge
into authentication, authorization.
What are the tools, and what tools,
and what type of calls those agents can do
on behalf of the user?
And how can you do the metadata,
the federation propagation
from the user identity
into what we call the
outbound authentication.
So we have introduced AgentCore Identity
that can help you with all this complexity
of managing the authentication
and authorization.
Great news about AgentCore
Identity, you can integrate
with your existing IdPs.
So if you're using
Cognito, you're using Okta,
or any custom provider
that supports OAuth,
you can just connect
to AgentCore Identity.
And AgentCore Identity will actually
call, on your behalf, those
providers to validate the token
and validate the credentials of your user.
So you're not trying to replace
your identity providers,
we're just trying to give you flexibility
to support both inbound and
outbound authentication.
And of course, everything you do here,
you wanna make sure
you have observability.
How do you make sure you
know what the agent is doing
if you need to troubleshoot?
Or you wanna make sure
you have regulatory, you know, compliance,
you're saving every single
step that, you know,
Dennis showed us a very complex workflow
that had dozens and dozens of steps?
How do you actually
collect every single step
that every single agent
took behind the scenes?
Every single large language model call,
every single tool call,
every single reasoning
chain of thought, prompt.
With AgentCore Observability,
you can either use Runtime
on AgentCore Gateway,
or you can even use outside AgentCore.
You can extract all that
information and ship to CloudWatch
or a third party observability provider
of your preference using OpenTelemetry.
And you have all the capability there.
And then finally, which I
think is a very important one,
is AgentCore Memory.
Let's say I'm a bank using
Moody's agentic AI systems,
and I would like the system to know
that, you know, I am from this bank
and I am a maybe part
of the investment bank
and I have these stocks on my portfolio.
Wouldn't it be awesome if
the system could actually
collect that data as I'm
interacting with the agent
and save for long-term purposes?
With AgentCore Memory, you have
this fully managed solution
that you can collect
both short-term memory,
which is just a
user-assistant interaction,
and automatically
extract insights for you,
preferences, summarizations,
or even your own custom
semantic information.
If you're interested in
AgentCore, there are a lot
of sessions available in re:Invent.
Highly recommend you checking it out.
But that is pretty much
it for our session.
Just wanna say thank you
so much for joining us.
And the last thing, please
rate us on the AWS Events app.
Our session ID is IND3303. And
thank you so much everyone.
(audience clapping)